boa tarde a todos
eu queria dizer pra vocês se já
começando a contar um segredo que o
tamanho da minha alegria é igual ao meu
nervosismo
eu sou psicóloga clínica e eu sou uma
psicóloga provocação
eu escolhi essa profissão porque eu
acredito realmente que a psicologia é a
profissão do futuro e não por
desqualificar as outras profissões mas
por acreditar no ser humano
ouvindo todos as pessoas ilustres que
nos trouxeram histórias e nos contaram
questões hoje fica muito claro que nós
devemos focar nas relações humanas
nós devemos focar nas pessoas como
psicóloga clínica
eu tenho muitos seios têm muitas dúvidas
muitas questões
eu me comovo e me conecto com o
sofrimento humano todos os dias além de
psicóloga clínica eu também decidi disse
a pesquisadora
porque qual pesquisadora eu tento buscar
hipóteses e levantar dúvidas sobre
possibilidades de intervenções
então a questão é o que será que eu
tenho pra contar pra vocês de idéias
inovadoras de questões para nós podermos
pensar e provavelmente vocês vão sair
daqui
a partir da minha palestra com mais
dúvidas certamente sem nenhuma resposta
mas o que eu vim contar pra vocês diz
respeito a idéias a questionamentos
há possibilidades para que a gente possa
ter um cotidiano mais tranqüilo mais
alegre
diante de todo esse universo que está
posto nos tempos que a gente vive
o que mais me comove e o que mais tem
inquietado diante do contato com as
outras pessoas
por incrível e nevrálgico que isso possa
parecer diz respeito à solidão eu tenho
identificado que as pessoas estão muito
solitárias e esta solidão me chega de
uma forma muitas vezes disfarçada
ela aparece muitas vezes na
de depressão outras vezes na forma de
ansiedade mas inegavelmente as pessoas
têm se sentido sozinhas e eu venho me
perguntando sobre a solidão eu venho me
questionando de onde vem essa solidão
porque é interessante como é que nós
podemos nos sentir só diante de tanta
conexão
provavelmente hoje durante o dia que
vocês estiveram aqui durante esses
períodos que vocês estão conosco
vocês estão conectados eles estão
conectados com o mundo lá fora
vocês estão conectados entre vocês vocês
estão conectados com as pessoas e as
novas tecnologias as novas mídias nos
trazem a questão da conexão então a
questão é por que que nós nos sentimos
sozinhos e eu venho levantando algumas
dúvidas em algumas questões acerca disso
são inúmeras as mudanças que a sociedade
vem trazendo as famílias estão
configurados de outras formas
a sociedade está configurada de outra
forma
isso não é positivo nem negativo nós
temos muitas mudanças que são
extremamente positivas
muitas mudanças mas nós temos algumas
mudanças que o que as pesquisas ea nossa
realidade vem trazendo é que elas podem
ser negativas quando a gente olha para
uma família que está sentada à mesa e
todos os participantes estão atrás de
equipamentos tecnológicos
a gente precisa pensar que tem alguma
coisa errada as relações de trabalho
também mudaram
vocês estão aqui provavelmente e
inundados por informações sobre o
trabalho de vocês provavelmente você
resolver inúmeros problemas
mesmo estando teoricamente no aqui e
agora
então diante dessa perspectiva
nós precisamos desenvolver outras
possibilidades de conexão
nós precisamos entender o mundo como
conectado em alguns pontos e
desconectado em outros pontos além de
psicóloga clínica
eu sou mãe e eu posso afirmar para vocês
que ser mãe é a principal tarefa que
executa todos os dias eu preciso fazer
um exercício constante
de me conectar com os meus filhos e essa
conexão de angústias
essa conexão faz com que eu precise
entender quais são as necessidades
emocionais dos meus filhos e essa
conexão me trazendo algumas angústias
também nós vivemos num período de
tecnologias nós vivemos um período de
ansiedade e provavelmente todos vocês já
sentiram a ansiedade constantemente essa
ansiedade ela nos inunda e desde que ela
seja num ponto positivo ela vai fazer
com que nós nos fechamos
eu falei para vocês que estava ansiosa
quando eu comecei essa apresentação
a minha ansiedade poderia também
paralisado
eu poderia não ter conseguido iniciar
essa conversa com vetos
eu poderia ter ficado paralisada
bloqueada
qual é a diferença entre a minha
ansiedade que me move ea minha ansiedade
que paralisa provavelmente a minha
motivação
a minha motivação de estar aqui
conversando com vocês a questão da
ansiedade tem feito com que outros
vetores sejam relativos a sensação que
nós temos é que o mundo está muito mais
acelerado e que nós temos cada vez menos
tempo
então diante desse vetor diante desta
lógica e dessa forma tem alguma coisa
errada porque nós temos a sensação de
que o tempo tá nos escapando de que essa
velocidade ela está imensamente a alta e
nós estamos cada vez mais ansiosos
então sim nós precisamos parar
nós precisamos respirar nós precisamos
viver e nós precisamos sentir diante
dessa inversão de tempo e velocidade
existem algumas questões que precisam
ser repensadas
qual é o limite que nós damos para essa
conexão
qual é o limite que nós estabelecemos
entre as relações que são postas na
nossa vida cotidiana que faz com que a
gente consiga respirar pará viver e
nesse momento
em que provavelmente vocês estão fazendo
uma avaliação do que ficou para trás
a sensação que nós temos é que nós
estamos atrasados
muita coisa aconteceu lá fora durante
esse período que vocês estão aqui talvez
novidades importantíssimas ocorreram na
vida de vocês e até mesmo no mundo e de
que forma vocês vão correr atrás desse
prejuízo
e aí como psicóloga como pesquisadora e
como mãe eu começo a pensar sobre
algumas questões que podem nos fazer
viver nesse ambiente que está posta e aí
o convido vocês a pensarem sobre o que a
gente pode fazer de diferente
eu gosto muito dessa palavra inovação
inovação semanticamente é desrespeito a
inovar a ação o que que é inovação o que
nós podemos fazer de diferente neste
mundo que está posto que nos faz várias
exigências e que faz com que além de
sermos producentes nós sejamos pessoas
saudáveis inovação diz respeito a alguns
itens de que forma a gente vai conseguir
pensar a nossa interação social
as nossas habilidades de relacionamento
levando em consideração a possibilidade
de inovação inovação diz respeito à
criatividade
nós precisamos encontrar alternativas
criativas para sair do lugar comum
além de idéias criativas nós precisamos
constantemente nos monitorarmos para que
a gente consiga ter método e disciplina
o método e disciplina são diferenciais
para que nós possamos atingir os nossos
objetivos
além de método disciplina a gente
precisa ter pensamento crítico porque o
mundo está disponível as informações
estão todas disponíveis nós temos um
montante de acesso de informações
só que a habilidade de pensar
criticamente sobre essas informações
precisa ser desenvolvido
além disso nós precisamos testar as
nossas hipóteses a gente precisa ter a
coragem de pôr o mundo e colocar nossas
idéias em prática
mas para além de criativo
adi método do pensamento crítico e
empirismo nós precisamos nos conectar
conexão diz respeito a estarmos juntos e
conectados não significa que estaremos
compartilhando a mesma rede wifi
conectarmos significa estarmos próximos
emocionalmente disponíveis e para nós
estarmos emocionalmente disponíveis nós
precisamos nos aproximar os a empatia é
um construto extremamente importante nas
relações afetivas
eu preciso estar aberta para me conectar
emocionalmente com vocês e vocês
precisam estar abertos para entrar em
contato com o que eu estou dizendo para
vocês eu espero sinceramente que neste
momento nós ainda estejamos conectados
vocês ainda estejam pensando e sentindo
que estou sentindo e aí uma grande
questão que vem quando a gente trabalha
com pessoas é como eu faço para ser
feliz
as pessoas perguntam isso quem procura
um psicólogo ou quem procura um amigo ou
quem procura um apoiador
geralmente está ocupado dessa pergunta
como eu faço para ser feliz
o google não vai responder isso
infelizmente eu não vou responder isso
pra vocês
quando eu disse no início da minha
apresentação que provavelmente vocês
sairão daqui com dúvidas
essa talvez seja uma dúvida agora o que
a gente tem buscado o que a gente tem
encontrado em pesquisas em teorias
psicológicas
a organização mundial da saúde traz um
conceito extremamente importante para
que a gente possa sobreviver à
modernidade
o conceito de habilidades de vida um
construto extremamente amplo habilidades
de vida
será que nós não nascemos configurados
para viver
eu posso afirmar para vocês que nós
temos configurados para sobreviver
talvez não para viver o que significa
viver significa ter habilidades
emocionais significa poder reconhecer a
minha ansiedade que quase me paralisou
e me conectar com você as significa
reconhecer que o processamento cognitivo
pode falhar eu posso esquecer coisas que
eu tinha me proposto a conversar com
vocês
mas além disso e muito para além nós
precisamos nos relacionar a gente
precisa ter respeito pelo outro
a gente pôde precisa poder cd a gente
precisa poder ser empático e eu preciso
olhar no olho de vocês e enxergar a alma
de vocês e eu preciso poder suportar
esse sofrimento por mais que vocês
estejam sofrendo e talvez junto a gente
consiga trilhar um caminho
essas são habilidades extremamente
importantes que o google não vai nos
responder
talvez vocês vai vocês me perguntem onde
é que a gente encontra essas respostas
na vida
além disso a gente também precisa
reconhecer as nossas emoções começa a
interação quando a gente se olha quando
a gente se conecta todas as emoções são
importantíssimas sejam elas primárias ou
secundárias alegria é uma delícia
a tristeza é importantíssimo
ela nos conecta o nojo nos protege
a surpresa é o brilho da vida
a surpresa e alegria são responsáveis
pela nossa vontade de continuar vivendo
a raiva é imprescindível para que a
gente nos mova e todas essas emoções
fazem com que nós estejamos disponíveis
e pré abertos pra essa conexão
então pensando nesse caminho emocional
de desenvolvimento de habilidades
sociais e desenvolvimento de habilidades
cognitivas nós precisamos inicialmente
fazer o reconhecimento das nossas
emoções
nesse momento eu faço uma busca quem é
que tá fazendo contato visual comigo
agora quem é que tá nesse momento
olhando pra mim e eu estou buscando um
feedback de vocês estou buscando regular
minha fala a partir do que vocês estão
me dizendo essa conexão ela tem que ser
intrínseca as pessoas precisam fazer
isso elas precisam se conectar em todas
as situações de relação que elas
estiverem e essa conexão que eu faço
quando estou dando aula
essa conexão eu faço quando estou com os
meus pacientes em consultório
isso não é exclusivo da minha profissão
eu convido todos a fazerem essa conexão
porque quando eu chego em casa exausta o
meu trabalho com uma sensação de que eu
tenho pouco tempo e muita velocidade em
todas as tarefas que eu preciso fazer eu
me conecto com os meus filhos e essa
conexão é extremamente gratificante
porque o objetivo que a gente atinja um
novo nível
é o objetivo que a gente consiga
desenvolver outras habilidades para que
eles possam ser pessoas felizes
é o objetivo que a partir dessa conexão
emocional a gente consiga planejar a
gente consiga desenvolver atividades
criativas a gente possa ter uma atenção
focada em tudo que nós estamos fazendo
a gente tem a motivação para viver e
para fazer as nossas atividades
cotidianas mas principalmente que a
gente se sinta conectado e eu convido
vocês a pensar sobre o mundo em que
todas as pessoas estão conectadas
emocionalmente
imaginem um mundo onde a gente consiga
acessar o nosso mundo emocional e onde a
gente consiga não tem medo das nossas
emoções que a gente possa validá las a
cada momento ea cada sensação eu
acredito piamente que quando nós nos
conectarmos e desenvolvemos habilidades
sociais emocionais e cognitivas
o mundo pode ser bem melhor muito
obrigado